[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه المقابله
الخاصه التي نجريها على هامش مؤتمر المناخ
في شرم الشيخ ينضم الينا على هامش هذه
القمه معالي الوزير عادل الجبير وزير شؤون
الخارجيه
ومبعوث الخاص للملف المناخي لدى المملكه
مع الوزير اهلا وسهلا بيك شكرا لتاحتك لنا
هذه الفرصه بدايه نبدا بالعنوان الاوسع
لربما في ظل خضم ازمات اقتصاديه ومخاوف من
ركود اقتصادي اضافه الى مخاوف من مستويات
التضخم وارتفاع نسب الفائده وازمه الطاقه
هل ما زال امن المناخ اولويه لدى دول
العالم بدون شك
موضوع المواجهه التحديات التغير المناخي
والتعامل مع البيئه اصبحت من اهم
الاوروبيات العلاقات الدوليه في العالم
واحنا نشاهدناها على مدى 30 و40 سنه اللي
فاتت في بدون شكل الموضوع من الاولويات
السعوديه على مدار السنوات القليله
الماضيه حقيقه المنذر 2014 نهايته حذرت
مرارا وتكرارا من انخفاض مستويات
الاستثمار في النفط والغاز وما ممكن ان
ياتي من ذلك مستقبلا من همم مسببات لازمات
طاقه اليوم نحن في خضم ازمه الطاقه هل
تعتقد السعوديه تاتي الى منصك بيئيه
مناخيه مثل الكاب تونتي 7 بثقه اكبر في
اعاده صياغه سرديه المفاوضات المناخيه اذا
نارتف همم حقت المفاوضات المناخيه حول عدم
التسرع بالانتقال ما دام البديل غير جاهز
الان
المملكه كانت تعبر عن تركها في ما يتعلق
بالانتاج البترول من عقد الثمانينات كانت
المملكه دائما تقول ان في حد في سقف اعلى
بالنسبه لانتاج البترول من الصعب تجاوزه
وعلى العالم ان ينظر في
مصادر الطاقه
الذي دائما في ارتفاع فهذه موقف المملكه
من عقد الثمانينات في من يتعلق بالبترول
بترول سيكون معنا على مدى عقود طويله همم
الهدف الان انه من اين نحصل على مصادر
اضافيه لتلبيه الطلب على الطاقه من قبل
العالم والمملكه همم
في هذا المكان سواء المجال همم الطاقه
الشمسيه المياه الرياح همم وغيرها من
الموارد الاساسي يكون عندك طاقه المستدامه
وتستطيع ان تلم بحاجه المجتمع الدولي
للطاقه همم طبعا معاليك احدى المبادرات
همم التي اطلقتها السعوديه قبل حوالي
العام قبل ايام من كلاسكو كانت مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء ومبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر يعني نتحدث عن المبادره الوطنيه
المبادره السعوديه الخضراء ماذا الانجاز
منها على مدار السنه التي همم انتهت الان
المبادره السعوديه الخضراء مبادره الشرق
لو سمحت ضمن استراتيجيه شامله بالنسبه
للمملكه للتعامل مع التغير المناخي
والتعامل مع البيئه ومن هناك في المملكه
اكثر من 60 مبادره تعني بموضوع البيئه
موضوع المناخ سواء كانت موضوع التشجير
مباره السعوديه الخضراء سواء كان بيتعلق
بخلق مناطق محميه همم تغطي على 30% من
اراضي المملكه مناطق محميه على البحار
تابعه للمملكه توصل الى 20% عندما تكمل
فيما يتعلق بالحياه الفطريه فيما يتعلق
بانتاج همم وصناعه الهيدروجين الاخضر فيما
يتعلق بتحويل النفايه الى طاقه وغيرها من
المبادرات العديده اللي من اجل همم
المساهمه لتحسين المناخ وتحسين البيئه
ومواجهه تحديات التغير المناخي ثم يتعلق
بممارسه السعوديه الخضراء هناك دراسات
عديده تم اكمالها هناك
اه مشاريع بالنسبه لتشجير تم وضعها عدد
هناك اشجار تمز زراعتها
وغيرها من النباتات الهدف من وراها انه
تقليس الكربون وتعزيز ااا
الانتاج الاكسجين
لكي تصبح المملكه التي توصل المملكه
للحياه الصفي التي تاسع اليه المملكه
لديها استراتيجيه شامله ومتكامله في موضوع
ما يسمى
كارد بالالكتروني
الدائري فلانا لا نعتقد ان هناك تناقد
انتاج البترول وبين همم
السعي من اجل مناخ وبيئه اصلا همم هناك
برامج زي همم
استخدام الطاقه بشكل افضل هناك برامج
لاستخدام طاقه متجدده واستدامه هناك برامج
زين اننا همم نخفف من الكربون المتواجد في
المناخ ومن ثم تخزينه وهناك ايضا برامج ل
همم خلق مزيد من
الاشياء الايجابيه على اساس يكون همم يكون
البرنامج المشروع برنامج شامل وبرنامج
متوازن مبني على اسس منطقيه او مبني على
همم العلم معاليك همم هذا بالنسبه
للمبادره الوطنيه السعوديه مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر وهمم همم هدف السعوديه في
مساعده دول المنطقه للوصول وتحقيق
التخفيضات في الانبعاثات التي اعلن عنها
ضمن مساهماتهم الوطنيه المحدده الام بي سي
سي لماذا تريد السعوديه لاعب هذا الدوري
الاقليمي فيما يخص الاقتصاد الاخضر والعمل
المناسب لا تستطيع بلد ان تعالج همم موضوع
البيئه والمناخ اييي بحد ذاتها لازم يكون
العمل العمل على مستوى
الاقاليم وعلى مستوى الدولي لما تيجي
عاصفه اخباريه ما توقف على حدودك وتقول
انا والله الف عليك واتفاداك لما جاء ال
فيروس كوبل ما فرق بين دون ناميه ودونا
صناعيه ما فرق بين ديانا معينه ما فرق بين
نعرف معين
كيفيه التعامل مع الجائحه هذه همم افضل
وسيله لسماحه للعالم يبدا في تجاوز هذه
الجائحه هو عن طريق التعاون
والتنسيق بالنسبه للجهود
الحوار والنقاش على اسس منطقيه واسس علميه
نفس الشيء بالنسبه للمناخر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تعلم انه لابد ان يكون
هناك تعاون دوله تعاون اقليمي فيما يتعلق
بالمناخ همم اذا جاءت عواصف رمليه ما تجيء
فقط السعوديه تجي من اماكن بعيده عن
السعوديه
ولابدنا نتعامل معها همم في مصدرها اساس
ايضا المملكه
تنظر الى النوم دول المنطقه همم
يجب ان يكون هناك تكاثر وتنسيق في الجهود
من اجل الوصول الى الاهداف المرجوه فهذه
كانت همم
الاهداف وراء مبادره الشرطه واوسط الخضراء
اريد ان اعرف منكم موقف السعوديه خلال همم
ما يعرف ببند اللص عند التعويضات عن
الخسائر والاضرار همم من قبل الدول
الصناعيه التي لديها تاريخ طويل في
الانبعاثات تاريخيه وهذه تعويض عن الاضرار
التي تتعرض لها دول اقل دخلا همم والتي
تتحمل الاضرار من دون ان يكون لها مساهمات
تاريخيه في ال- في ال- في الانبعاثات
ما زالت دول الصناعيه الكبرى متاخره على
صعيد هذه التعويضات ما موقف السعوديه من
هذا البنك لو ننظر للموضوع بشكل شامل
وبشكل تاريخي واجبنا انه هناك فيها
اتهامات وفي انتقادات من من جميع الاطراف
على سبيل المثال في هناك من يكون من الدول
الصناعيه هي اللي مسؤوله على الوضع لنجل
نفسنا فيه بسبب 120 سنه من العصر الصناعي
ولذلك عليها مسؤوليه ان تعالج هذه المشكله
وعلى الدول العالم المسؤوليه ان تعمل سواء
لمعالجه المواضيع المستقبليه هذا المنظر
هناك ايضا همم
اتفاهم حدث في اتفاقيه في قمه باريس على
انه يكون في صندوق
بحوالي 100 مليون دولار في السنه لمساعده
الدول الناميه على التعامل مع المواضيع
البيئه والتغير المناخي وهناك كان
الالتزام ايضا لنقل التقنيه المطلوبه لهذه
الدول هناك انتقادات من قبل الدول الناميه
ان المبالغ هذه لم تاتي وانه التقنيه همم
لم يتم تقديمها لهم فهذه ال ال ال ال
الاخت والعطا لازال مستمر
الواقع
والحقيقه انه العالم في وضع سيء وان هناك
حاجه للتعامل مع هذه التحديات
لانقاذ كوكبنا ولخلط مستقبل افضل لاولادنا
واحفادنا وهذا ما يتم عن طريق توجيه
الاتهامات او عن طريق التعبير عن المشاعر
هذا يتم عن طريق الحوار المنطقي والبناء
والذي مبني على اسس علميه نعتقد انه في
مسؤوليه
لابد تحمل هذه المسؤوليه
واعتقت ان هناك ادراك من قبل الدول
الصناعيه في هذا الموضوع والان في نقاش
حول بعض الاليات وبعد التفاصيل وبعد بس
هذه الامور قانونيه اعتقد المهم انه يكون
فيه
التعاون المهم ان يكون فيه نقاش مبني على
المنطق وليس على العواطف والمساعد من جميع
الاطراف وان يكون فيه التزام جدي ليه
معالجه التعاون التعامل مع التحديات الى
نواجهها ويكون هناك التزام جدي بتنفيذ
الوعود الذي تم طرحها من قبل الدول
الصناعيه تجاه الدول الناميه ولكن ما عليك
هل تعتقد بانه هذه نسب الالتزام هذه جيده
في ضوء توجه اوروبا التي طالما كانت
المبشر بالتحول الى الطاقات النظيفه
لاستخدام المزيد من الفحم اليوم نستخدم في
زمن شرم الشيخ فحم اكثر في اوروبا من ما
كانت تستخدمه في كلاسكو السنه الماضيه هل
تكيل بمكيالين هنا اوروبا انا مثل ما ذكرت
همم
اعتقد انه الحوار بالنسبه لموضوع التغير
المناخي مليء بالمشاعر والعواطف
ويسقد المنطق والعلم
ولما يكون الحوار مليء بالمشاعر
تجد في تناقضات على سبيل المثال الدول
الاوروبيه تفرض ضرائب 200% على البترول
واحد الحجاج انه المناخ في نفس الوقت
يقدمون مساعدات للفحم الذي اسوا للمناخ من
البترول المنطقه
في عندك هناك مطالبات بعدم الاعتماد على
البترول والفحم
وبعد ما صارت الازمه في اوكرانيا صار في
مطالبات برفع انتاج الفحم والبترول هذه
هذه
المواقف المتناقضه
اساسها
الحوار الذي ليس مبني على منطق وعلى امور
علميه
الوقود الاحفوري سوائل البترول او الفحم
حيث يستمر مع العالم على مدى عقود
التغيير ما يصير فيهم وليله صغير حيصير
تدريجي هناك حاجه ترتفع للطاقه في العالم
لانه ما نستطيع ان نلبي هذه الحاجه الا
اذا وجدنا همم مصادر الطاقه
سواء كانت شمسيه سواء كانت من الرياح سواء
كانت لابد لانه الانتاج بالنسبه للبنات
البترول في حد لا نستطيع ان ننتج اعلى منه
فاذا كان الهدف انه توفير الطاقه للعالم
لابد يكون فيه طاقه
اضافيه
المملكه
لا بد يكون فيه همم مصادر اخرى للطاقه غير
البترول اه نرجع مره ثانيه للنقطه اللي
طرحتها انه موضوع التناقض واضح ان في
تناقص اذا كنا حنبني مواقفنا همم على اساس
همم
مشاعر وليس على اساس المنطق وعلم وحتى
هيكون في تناقض وما حتكون المواقف سليمه
السؤال الاخير معاليك ما هو البند او
المخرج الذي اذا خرجت به قمه شرم الشيخ
تعتقد بانه كانت ناجحه ما الذي تتطلع اليه
كابرز مخرجات شرم الشيخ
الى قمه شرم الشيخ كان ال ال الحديث عن
الخطر وعلى التحديات الكل يعلم الخطر
[موسيقى]
ذوبان
الاخطاء كلنا نعرف الموضوع توسعه الصحراء
كلنا نعمل
الارتفاع الحراره يعني
النار تنظفه على مدى عقود والناس
استوعبتهم
الان علينا ان نتحول الى التنفيذ علينا ان
نتحول الى وضع مبادرات
للتعامل مع المشكله
والكل يدرك اهميه معالجتها ما يحتاج تسمع
الكلام هذا نحتاج الى مبادرات
لايجاد من اجل ايجاد حلول لهذه التحديات
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه لدينا اكثر من
60 مبادره في الداخل كما ذكر
ولدينا مبادرات بالنسبه للسعوديه الخضراء
والشرق الاوسط الاخضر
الجهود وتكثيف الجهود من اجل تخفيف
الكربون ومن اجل الرفع
المستوى الاوكسجين ول- همم الذين همم
طاقه مصادر الطاقه اضافيه مثل الشمس مثل
الرياح وغيرها المشاريع التي تقوم بها
المملكه في المجال السياحه مثلا لدينا
الان مشاريع بالنسبه للسياحه المستدامه
على اساس نستفيد من الزوار للمملكه وفي
نفس الوقت نساهم في تحسين
البيئه والمناخ ونعتقد انه المهم هو
الافعال وليس الاقوال وانا متفائل انه في
قمه شرم الشيخ همم لاحظ انه فيه بدا تحول
اتجاه التنفيذ وتجاه ايجاد الحلول فلعلها
تستمر في هذا الاتجاه نستطيع همم
مناخ بيئه افضل لنا ولطفانا واللي احزان
على امل معاليك انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
وجودك معنا وطبعا الملف المناخي ملف متشعب
و يلمس الكثير من الملفات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا كان معنا معالي وزير عادل الجبير
وزير الدوله الشؤون الخارجيه
وطبعا المبعوث الخاص للملف المناخي
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه شكرا لحسن
المتابعه
[موسيقى]